[Musique]
Messieurs, bonjour.
Bonjour Bertrand.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle Sinkerview,
une chaîne internet. Euh donc comme
Jacques
nous nous il m'a déstabilisé d'un coup
là.
Oui. Donc on vous reçoit aujourd'hui
pour vos domaines d'expertise
respectif, Jacques Blamont qui est
fondateur du programme spatial français
qui a a participé à envoyer des ballons
sur Vénus et Pablo Servigne, je vais
vous laisser aussi vous présenter après
Jacques. Jacques, est-ce que vous voulez
bien vous présenter succintement ? Je
suis physicien, j'ai fait mes études de
l'École normale supérieure et ça m'a
amené comme professeur à Sorbon à 30
ans. À ce moment-là, on m'a demandé de
changer ce que ce que je faisais et de
m'occuper du programme spatial français
où il y avait rien. Et ça se passait en
1957 au moment de Spoutnik. Euh, il y
avait quelques fusées sondes qui étaient
prévues pour l'année géophysique
internationale dans le programme
français. Et donc on m'a donné cette os
arrangé et j'ai proposé des expériences
qui ont très bien marché et dont la en
fait la conséquence a été le démarrage
de tout le programme français spatial et
la création par le général de Gaulle du
KNES. Lorsque le KNES a été créé, on m'a
demandé d'être le premier directeur
technique et scientifique, ce que je
suis resté pendant 12 ans. Et après ça,
je suis resté au Kness comme haut
conseiller scientifique et j'y suis
encore comme conseiller du président
bénévole.
Pablo Servigne, fait votre présentation.
Moi je suis tout petit. J'ai Non, moi
j'ai une formation scientifique euh
auteur et conférencier. J'écris des
livres, des articles, je fais des
conférences.
Euh scientifique, d'abord agronome et
après étologue. J'ai fait de
comportement animal. J'ai fait ma thèse
quelques années de recherche et j'ai
arrêté la recherche académique et j'ai
fait de l'éducation populaire.
Euh écrire des articles, faire des
conférences et transmettre la passion de
la science et pas que la science
d'ailleurs au grand public.
Donc Jacques Blamont a écrit un livre
qui s'appelle Introduction au siècle des
menaces. C'est pour ça que on a fait
venir Pablo Servi pour en discuter un
peu. Qu'est-ce que vous racontez dans ce
dans ce livre là ?
C'est un livre qui qui a été écrit il y
a une quinzaine d'années qui est apparu
en 2004 chez Odil Jacob. C'est un livre
qui essayait de décrire un certain
nombre de caractères de notre siècle.
Ce qui m'intéressait particulièrement,
c'était l'évolution des systèmes
électroniques qui a été à la base de
changement historique.
Ça ne s fait que s'accélérer depuis et
ça m'a amené à considérer toutes les
difficultés
qui attendent l'humanité. Et donc en
fait, c'est un gros livre fait la liste
et l'analyse d'une série de dangers. Et
le point principal, c'est que pour moi,
chacune des menaces qui se sont
concrétisé, par exemple comme la menace
climatique, chacune des menaces se
disons se couple avec les autres. Et
donc on pourrait peut-être échapper à
l'une, mais on ne peut sans doute pas
échapper au complexe de l'ensemble de
ces menaces. Et c'est ça qui est le
sujet principal du livre.
Comment comment vous voyez le le pouvoir
politique gérer cette grande liste ?
Est-ce que vous voyez une force
politique prendre les choses en main ?
Est-ce que vous voyez la la force
publique prendre les choses en main ?
Est-ce que le public est conscient de
ces menaces là ?
Je vous répondrai d'abord sur votre
question sur les pouvoirs publics. Euh
je pense que le le problème échappe
complètement au pouvoir politique. Et
d'ailleurs, on peut trouver un exemple
très simple, c'est que il y a eu la COP
21 il y a maintenant 3 ans ou quelque
chose comme ça
et tous les États ont promis d'améliorer
leur bilan carbone. Rien n'a été fait
par aucun gouvernement de paix. Et en
particulier, c'est très curieux, c'est
que le gouvernement français qui a fait
Cocorico avec avec le rôle qu'il jouait
dans la disons la réunion
n'a pas fait plus que les autres et le
disons que notre consommation en corbone
a augmenté depuis consommation de la
France. Ça c'est simplement un exemple,
mais en réalité je pense que nous sommes
devant des grandes tendances, des
tendances de fond. Euh l'essentiel,
c'est très clair, provient de
l'augmentation de la population 1 % par
an. Mais ce n'est pas tout. Il y a
quelque chose encore plus grave, c'est
que non seulement la population mondiale
augmente, mais que en même temps elle
veut améliorer son niveau de vie, se
développer. Et donc si la croissance de
la population est de l'ordre de 1 % par
an, la croissance des la consommation
des ressources naturelles euh qui
servent à disons augmenter le niveau de
est de 2 % pardon.
Et donc nous sommes en présente
stationnaire, c'est-à-dire que il
s'aggrave pas, il faudrait 0 % pardon.
Mais avec 2 % d'augmentation de la
consommation des ressources naturelles,
le système est instable et ne peut pas
être arrêté. Et alors ces deux facteurs
augmentation de la population et
augmentation de son niveau de vie, son
développement sont complètement en
dehors du disons des moyens d'action des
gouvernements. Et donc c'est pour ça que
je pense que les gouvernements ne
peuvent rien faire.
Pablo Serv, est-ce que vous voulez
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
Jacques ?
Non, je suis d'accord depuis le début.
Enfin, le côté systémique est vraiment
intéressant.
Quand on a écrit le livre en 2015,
c'était juste avant la COP 21. C'était
le
quel livre comment tout peut s'effondrer
au seuil. On apportait justement, on a
écrit le livre qu'on vous qu'on rêvait
de lire en fait. C'est-à-dire qu'on a
des des analyses en silo. Il y a les
climatologues qui parlent de des risques
et des menaces, l'énergie, la finance,
l'économie, la biodiversité et peu
d'analyses transdisciplinaire,
systémiques, global
et peu de connaissance sur les systèmes
complexes, sur les réseaux, sur les
effets de seuil, sur les effets de
contagion et cetera. Donc moi, j'ai
malheureusement lu votre livre un peu
vite d'ailleurs et après avoir publié le
nôtre, mais ça ça se rejoint sur
beaucoup de constats et sur la
population,
ben on voit clairement qu'on a atteint
des limites planétaires du système
terre. Il y a deux moyens, on réduit la
population et où on réduit le niveau de
vie. Et pour l'instant, on sait faire ni
l'un ni l'autre. et et ça inclut la
question des inégalités parce que plus
on a des ultra riches qui consomment
beaucoup, plus les pauvres et les ultra
pauvres veulent leur ressembler dans une
course effrainée euh à la consommation,
à la destruction.
Jacques euh vous venez de fêter vos 92
ans la semaine dernière.
Oui, c'est exact.
Comment vous voyez notre société du 21e
siècle ? Est-ce que la machine s'est
emballée ? Oui. Euh moi je pense que le
la consommation va continuer et vous
voyez ce que j'indiquéis sur
l'augmentation de la consommation euh
correspond au fait suivant. Euh tout le
monde estime que l'humanité atteindra à
peu près 10 milliards
d'humains envers 2050.
Mais si on tient compte de
l'augmentation de leurs besoins, c'est
l'équivalent
de 14 milliards. Ça veut dire qu'en
2050, il faudrait nourrir
14 milliards de gens et non pas 10 et
non pas 7 comme aujourd'hui. Et donc euh
ce n'est pas possible.
ce qui ce qui va se produire, c'est que
il va y avoir une augmentation de la
consommation de tous les biens. Et quand
je dis bien ou ressources naturelles,
c'est très général. par exemple les
terres arables, par exemple l'atmosphère
qui est un bien et qui est disons
attaqué par pour de façon à à fournir le
changement climatique. Et il y a
d'autres d'autres ressources naturelles
qui sont encore plus menacées et
naturellement celle qui vient à l'esprit
et qui est et qui va connaître
une aggravation, c'est la ressource en
eau.
qui on considère déjà ce qui s'est passé
dans les quelques dernières années en ce
qui concerne la quantité disponible
d'eau dans le bassin méditerranéen. On
s'aperçoit que les crises politiques ou
militaires ou sont viennent
de des sécheresses de problèmes de
l'eau.
On a commencé à partir de 1970
à pomper dans toutes les nappes
fréatiques, y compris les nape fossile
qui ne se renouvelle pas. Et donc on
atteint maintenant un niveau où
la situation puisqu'on a consommé notre
capital, la situation va s'aggraver
rapidement. Si je prends un exemple, le
Yémen, le Yémen, il y a il y a des
conflits, il y a des choses très graves.
Euh
quelle est la situation d'un aprire au
Yémen ? Elle était à 10 m de profondeur
en 1970. Aujourd'hui, elle est 1 km. Ça
veut dire que maintenant il faut pomper
et et on est en présence d'ailleurs du
surpompage, c'est-à-dire ce pompage vie
de la napriéatique. Or le Yémen a
aujourd'hui à peu près une vingtaine de
millions d'habitants et en 2050 et ça
sera 45. En 2050, vous aurez 45
héménites et à ce moment-là il y aura
plus d'eau du tout. Euh si l'on euh
disons essaie de quantifier ce
phénomène, euh les spécialistes disent
que il y a la population est en état de
stress hydrique, c'est-à-dire de stress
du en dessous de 2000 m³ par an et par
personne. Tous les pays du Maghreb,
l'Égypte, le Yémen
sont tous étaient tous en 2000 au niveau
juste en dessous du stressétique. Et si
maintenant on descend de 2000 à 1000 m³,
ça on appelle ça l'état de pénurie, à ce
moment-là, on s'aperçoit qu'en 2050 tous
les États, l'ensemble de tous les États,
y compris le Maghreb, y compris l'Égypte
sera en état de pénurie. Et je viens de
vous dire que 1000 m³, c'est le niveau
de la pénurie. Le Yémen sera 100.
Et donc nous avons déjà eu un yéméénine
qui a posé une bombe à New York il y a
pas très longtemps. Et donc ce qui se
produit, c'est que les pénuries
engendrent les conflits, les conflits
politiques et cetera comme la Syrie. Le
conflit de Syrie a commencé par une
sécheresse extrêmement grave à partir
20068 qui a forcé
les révolutions arabes aussi avec les
émeutes de la fin.
Oui. Oui. Naturellement. Mais c'était
c'était comment dirais-je ?
limité dans le temps. Les émeutes de la
fin s'approvenaient de disons de
mauvaise gestion des stocks et cetera
tandis que là euh les causes des
conflits seront les véritables pénuries
qu'on ne saura pas réglé.
Par exemple, je vais en Inde assez
souvent,
je vois des villes comme Haer Rabad,
comme Badras qui s'appelle maintenant
Chenaï, qui sont des villes qui sont
passées de 500000 à 5 millions
d'habitants en 20 ans. Euh,
elle pompe
d'une façon excessive
dans la nappe fratique locale et donc
ces gens-là n'auront plus à boire dans
une dizaine d'années. Je vais donner la
parole à Pablo.
Ouais. Sur l'eau, il y a il y a
plusieurs choses. Euh il y a il y a il y
a les nappes fréatiques. Il y a aussi
les les glaciers, par exemple en Inde,
Bangladesh, Pakistan et cetera, les
glaciers sont en train de fondre. et la
Chine récupère tout ça
à cause en plus et à cause du
réchauffement climatique. Il y aura
bientôt enfin il y a de moins en moins
d'eau qui arrivent et là ça crée des
conflits géopolitiques majeurs avec une
édification de murs et puis c'est des
pays aussi qui ont la bombe nucléaire,
faut pas le l'oublier. Et donc j'avais
vu une étude il y a pas longtemps, je
crois que c'était dans Nature où il
disait ils analysaient l'état des
comment dire des de l'eau en fonction
des populations. Et il y a deux zones
trois zones ils ont à haut risque pour
la la disponibilité en eau des
populations et contrairement à ce qu'on
croit enfin c'est contreintuitif c'est
l'Inde, la Chine et l'Europe. Pourquoi
l'Europe, les pays riches ? Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il y a une densité de
population très élevée. Et en fait,
c'est pas simplement, c'est très
important l'accès à l'eau naturelle,
mais il y a aussi le la potabilisation,
le traitement de l'eau et la
distribution de l'eau qui est qui est
consommateur d'énergie, de ressources,
de beaucoup d'énergie. Ça veut dire que
l'accès en eau des Européens moyens, il
dépend d'un système artificiel qui
dépend de ressources, d'énergie, de
terre rare et cetera et d'ingénieur
d'une complexité administrative
technique qu'on doit maintenir en place
qui est très complexe et très cher. Donc
c'est c'est une sorte de enfin on vit
sur sur une sorte de coussin artificiel
très vulnérable.
Alors vous parlez tous les deux vous
parlez tous les deux d'eau, vous parlez
tous les deux de climat. Est-ce que vous
avez lu le dernier rapport du JC ?
Le résumé,
il y a rien de rien de nouveau. Le GC a
s'est mis peu à peu d'accord sur une
certaine euh disons analyse euh et cette
analyse ils ne font que l'approfondir
mais je n'ai pas vu quelques faits
nouveaux par rapport à ce qui a été dit.
C'est-à-dire que euh
il y a il y a un changement climatique
et ce changement climatique, on a
raconté que il est disons, il se traduit
par d'un certain un changement en degré
centrade sur toute la planète. Euh étant
donné que pour un changement de 5° C,
on a un âge polaire, c'està-dire que il
y avait il y a il y a 5°grés entre l'âge
polaire et maintenant. Et donc ça veut
dire que quand on dit un ou deux degrés,
c'est très sérieux. Le JC s'est battu
pour euh forcer les gouvernants à
accepter comme objectif stratégique un
changement mondial de 1°gr 5. C'est tout
à fait ridicule.
Il est pas question de s'arrêter un
degré 5. On va certainement le dépasser
assez rapidement. C'est un peu ce que
dit le J. C'est-à-dire que le 1°gr 5, il
est il est déjà mort.
Jacques, on est dans la merde. Est-ce
qu'on est dans la merde ? Ah oui, tout à
fait. Euh parce que il n'y a pas il n'y
a pas que l'eau, il y a beaucoup
d'autres facteurs. Euh mes amis indiens
font euh une disons ont des satellites
qui euh observent euh les cultures et
disons l'ensemble de la verdure sur le
sous-continent.
Or, le sous-continent, il mourrait de
faim en lorsqu'en 2050,
on a inventé la révolution verte.
Pas en 2050, en 1950.
Oui, excusez-moi. En 1950, on y a
inventé la révolution verte. La
révolution verte, ça consistait à
irriguer et à mettre de l'engrais et le
résultat c'est spectaculaire. l'Inde
maintenant a pu atteint atteint une
capacité de de auto autoffisance
autosuff de suffisance
et bien maintenant on constate que les
champs qui sont irrigués
se saliniifient c'est-à-dire que quand
on met de l'eau dessus le sel remonte à
la surface et le résultat c'est que le
rendement des cultures diminuent et il y
avait a fait beaucoup de deux beaucoup
d'endroits où il y avait deux récoltes
par an et maintenant une récolte. Donc
ça signifie que les terres arables,
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure sont un
une ressource et sont essentiellement
surexploité. Et donc qu'est-ce qui va se
passer lorsque nous aurons un en Inde
comme l'avais dit une une pénurie en
eau. Il y a des mesures qui ont été
faites par le satellite allemand Grèce
de la de la nappe fréatique en Inde et
sur le sous tout sur tout le
sous-continent et on voit qu'elle est en
voie de réceptorion.
Le changement climatique va amener en
même temps une modification profonde et
peut-être un arrêt de la mousse. Et donc
voilà et vous avez plus d'un milliard de
gens en Inde qui vont se retrouver avec
des ressources agricoles très diminuées
et des ressources en eau allant vers le
zéro. J'ai lu récemment pour aller dans
votre sens un livre qui a été roman de
science-fiction qui a été publié par
l'ancien chef d'étatmajor de l'armée
indienne. Je me trouve un bangalore.
J'ai trouvé ce livre, je l'ai trouvé
très intéressant. Et alors cette
science-fiction indique quelle sera la
première guerre entre la Chine et
l'Inde. Et donc il explique que ça
commence par une décision chinoise de
barrer le bramapoutre et de façon
euh utiliser les eaux en haut.
Évacuez votre chat que vous avez dans la
gorge. Je vais donner la la parole à
Pablo.
Juste quel est le titre du roman ? Vous
vous souvenez ?
Je vous je ne m'en souviens pas. Non.
Non, il faut que je note ça. On le
notera. On
Mais je vous donnerai je vous donnerai
la référence à un livre très intéressant
parce que c'est pas un petit rigolo qui
a fait ça.
C'est un livre qui parle de militaire,
il décrit la guerre.
Moi j'ai j'ai juste pour revenir au JC,
il y a il y a deux choses en fait. Le JC
et la synthèse de publications qui sont
déjà un petit peu passé il y a quelques
mois. Ça va très vite en climatologie.
Et euh et du coup il ils disent, c'est
un rapport spécial hein, c'est juste le
résumé qui dit il est encore possible
d'aller vers 1 et demi degré. J'y crois
pas entre nous mais c'est le message qui
veulent faire passer. En gros, on va
peut-être vers trois et en fait euh il y
a deux choses inquiétantes. La première
c'est une étude dont je vais vous parler
qui est par cet été que le JC n'a pas
parlé. La deuxième, c'est que le J
commence à parler des solutions
techniques et de possible
géo-ingénierie,
de le nucléaire, la filière nucléaire
sans qu'elle est en train de s'effondrer
financièrement, que voilà, on y croit
plus trop et cetera et ils sont en train
de se réinventer sur un petit nucléaire
peut-être un peu plus sûr. Enfin voilà,
c'est en discussion. L'argument
climatique, c'est évidemment euh du pain
béni pour le la filière nucléaire. Et
donc on a on a voilà pour moi c'est des
solutions encore technocientiste qui
sont encore plus dangereuses que les
problèmes qu'on avait. Donc, il y a un
risque majeur. Là, je reviens à l'étude
euh qui est par le 6 août dans les
compte-rendus de l'Académie de Sciences
des États-Unis euh d'une de d'un peu la
même équipe qui avait fait la super
étude dans Nature en 2012 sur le
possible basculement de toute la
biosphère euh dans un état invivable en
voilà en quel dans dans quelques temps
on pourrait basculer vers un état
globalement insupportable pour la
majorité des espèces sur terre. Et en
fait, ils ont remis le couvert.
Et qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ? Ils disent
que en fait, il y a 15 grandes boucles
de rétroaction juste au je parle du
climat dans le climat genre la fonte du
permafrost, la fonte de la la calotte
polaire, euh les courants océaniques et
cetera. Et ils disent qu' il y a trois
sortes de grandes boucles de
rétroaction. La les premières qui se
déclenchent à + 1 + 3° sont déjà
énormes. Il y a les moyennes qui se
déclenchent à + 3 + 5° et il y a celle
qui se déclenche à plus de + 5°. Et le
problème, c'est ce qu'ils disent, c'est
que les premières boucles ont la
capacité de déclencher les deuxièmes,
les moyennes qui déclencheraient
l'ensemble des boucles de rétroaction.
Ce qui fait qu'on irait très vite vers
une trajectoire thermodynamique de
planète étuve, hot earth.
Et les scientifiques nous disent en fait
on est dans une pirogue, on voit le
courant accélérer, ça remue, on peut
plus ramer en arrière, c'est trop tard.
Et devant, il y a les scientifiques qui
disent "Oh, regardez, il y a il y a un
grand vide à 200 mroidération."
Par contre, l'équipe dit, et c'est un
peu comme le GC, regardez là sur la
gauche, il y a encore un petit rocher,
on peut espérer s'accrocher si on rame
tous ensemble maintenant à fond et de
manière coordonnée et tous c'est
l'humanité et je pense qu'on est
d'accord pour dire que c'est quand même
mal barré. Mais il y a une petite
chance, c'était le message de l'étude.
Et encore, si on arrive à s'accrocher au
petit rocher, ça veut dire plus 2 de
moyenne, ce qui est déjà catastrophique
parce que ça a la capacité de quand même
déclencher des petites boucles ou de se
prendre une vague qu'on avait pas prévue
ou éventuellement, s'il y en a dans la
pirogue qui ont décidé de refoutre le
bordel, bah de de basculer la pirogue
vers la planète et tu veux. Donc voilà
où on en est. Jacques, euh est-ce que la
science et la technologie vont nous
sauver ?
Je ne le crois pas. Euh pour ça, j'ai
une une idée générale euh qu'on peut
accepter ou pas accepter, mais je crois
qu'elle est très profonde.
De quoi souffrons-nous ? Euh nous avons
une évolution qui est à l'heure actuelle
entièrement
dirigée par la technologie et la
science. C'est un c'est c'est un fait.
par exemple l'augmentation de la
population, c'est la médecine qui s'est
amélioré et cetera et donc on ne peut
pas améliorer une situation qui est d à
la technologie en ajoutant de la
technologie. Alors parce que il y a
beaucoup de gens surtout en Amérique qui
disent "L'humanité s'en sortira, elle
s'en est toujours sortie. On trouvera le
malin, on trouvera des solutions. Je ne
pense pas du tout que les solutions se
doit soient de caractère technologique.
Chaque fois qu'on a un progrès
technologique et bien ça fait un progrès
dans la consommation. J'avais vu par
exemple le progrès dans la dans la
technologie de l'automobile en 50 ans,
on a divisé par de la consommation
d'essence pour faire marcher un moteur
avec l'idée que on ferait baisser la
consommation d'essence. Et bien ce qui
s'est produit c'est que comme la licence
est devenue moins cher
disons l'utilisation des voitures sont
devenues moins chères et le nombre
d'automobile a augmenté à doublé dans la
même période. Et ça c'est à mon avis un
exemple assez parlant puisque on
augmente la technologie et le résultat
c'est que le on augmente aussi la
consommation et le problème est je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure en début le problème
est l'augmentation de la consommation.
Le public commence à bien avoir saisi le
problème climatique.
La presse en parle énormément.
Euh même les hommes politiques en
parlent beaucoup, bien qu'ils ne fassent
rien, ils peuvent rien faire. Euh et
donc euh disons le public pense que nous
sommes dans une évolution du climat et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est bien
entré dans les esprits. Mais à mon avis,
ce n'est qu'un seul aspect. Comme je dis
tout à l'heure, il y a une série
considérable de ressources naturelles
qui sont en même temps menacé par une
consommation qui augmente. Et c'est la
synergie de sous ces pénuries qui crara
les conflits. Alors donc ce n'est quel
que soit le sujet euh ce n'est pas avec
la technologie qu'on sentira,
c'est avec la spiritualité.
Oui, c'està-dire qu'il y a une deuxième
une deuxième solution
ça pour qu'on à laquelle on peut penser,
c'est la solution politique,
c'est-à-dire ce que vous venez de dire,
c'est-à-dire l'humanité serait d'accord
pour se raccrocher à un petit rocher et
à prendre les mesures qui permettraient
d'arrêter l'évolution.
Ceci est impossible et ça n'arrivera
pas. Et pour ça, je prends une citation
véritablement limpide du président
George Bus Leè qui a dit au moment de la
conférence de Rio en 1992,
le niveau de vie des États-Unis n'est
pas négociable.
Le niveau de vie des États-Unis n'est
pas négociable. Et ça veut dire c'est
véritable parce que c'est vrai, tout le
monde comprend que oui, c'est vrai, il
est pas négociable. vous avez
qu'entendre monsieur Trump qui veut
l'augmenter beaucoup et donc s'il n'est
pas négociable, ça veut dire que comme
le niveau de vie des pays développés en
particulier repose sur la croissance, et
bien ça signifie que un tous les
gouvernements sont d'accord sur ce
fameux pas négociable et tout leur
pouvoir électoral repose sur
augmentation de la croissance. Et donc
on voit bien que il n'y a pas de
solution d au pouvoir politique que
qu'il s'agisse euh des pouvoirs
politiques dans les pays ou à aux
Nations Unies. Le problème est
exactement le même. Et je vous dis cette
phrase de George Bouche est tout à fait
profonde et elle est à la racine
de l'impossibilité.
euh que nous avons euh de d'avoir une
action politique. Et c'est pour ça que
par exemple moi les l'idodie de monsieur
Hulot m'ont m'ont paru véritablement
sans issue. Un ministre ne peut rien
faire.
Quoi qui quoi quel que soit sa son
discours, et bien ce n'est pas possible.
Le niveau de vie n'est pas négociable.
Alors maintenant effectivement comme je
l'avais dit pour moi il n'y a qu'une
seule solution
c'est le recours au pouvoir spirituel et
en fait parce pourquoi parce que nous
sommes en présence d'un d'une certaine
doctrine que j'appellerai la doctrine du
consumérisme euh de la doctrine euh de
toujours plus toujours augmentation euh
de la consommation
et donc ce qui est nécessaire
C'est un changement général de paradigme
où effectivement
la phrase de bouche soit abandonné. Et
ça ça ne peut être que par des moyens
spirituels. Et donc là, je ne suis pas
du tout sûr qu'ils existent et mais il
me semble que c'est dans cette direction
là, c'est-à-dire vers les pouvoirs
spirituels pour lesquels je n'ai aucune
sympathie d'ailleurs, mais vers les
pouvoirs spirituels qu'il faut se
tourner pour essayer de les convaincre,
d'aller vers le changement de paradigme
et de parler à leurs ouailles pour
effectivement transformer ce
consumérisme.
Pablo sur la spiritualité.
Ouais. Alors là, je je suis assez
d'accord mais peut-être j'entends quand
vous parlez de spirituel, j'entends
religieux parce que il y a pouvoir
derrière. Pour moi, les le les
religions, c'est les institutions et
donc les structures de pouvoir qui
tentent de gérer un peu le spirituel
plus ou moins maladroitement.
Moi, j'aimerais bien distinguer
spirituel et religieux parce que je
pense qu'il y a des spiritualités
laïques, donc non religieuse
et il y a des religions
non spirituelles, c'est-à-dire des
religions qui disent "Bon, vous
appliquez le petit livre, les petites
règles, je sais pas moi, le salafisme ou
je sais pas quoi, vous réfléchissez pas,
on s'en fout de votre vie intérieure et
vous y allez". Il y a rien de spirituel
là-dedans, c'est juste une une structure
de pouvoir. Voilà.
Euh ce que ce que Jacques propose
d'aller s'adresser aux structures de
pouvoir, moi je dirais religieuses pour
parce que elles ont des croyants et
parce que c'est un levier d'action, je
pense que c'est une bonne idée en soi.
Mais il y a pas il y a pas que ça. C'est
une des un des un des leviers possibles.
Moi et du coup ça pose la question
d'avoir éclaté cette définition, la
question du spirituel qui est qui pour
moi est vachement intéressante.
Alors je suis pas un spécialiste moi
j'ai un passé atât pratiquant militant
rationnel scientifique. Je crois qu'on
doit se rejoindre là-dedans. Par contre
j'ai découvert
beaucoup de choses dans alors récemment
c'est le livre de Dominique Bourg le
philosophe qui m'a un peu décomplexé
là-dessus. son livre s'appelle une
nouvelle terre et il disait la
spiritualité en fait c'est simplement
deux choses. C'est un notre rapport au
monde et à ce qui nous est donné quand à
la naissance tout nous est donné. Le le
sein de notre mère, le la nature, tout
ce qu'on a pas produit dans notre vie
nous est donné. Quel rapport on
entretient avec tout ça ? Tout ce qui
nous dépasse, tout l'univers, tout ce
qui nous dépasse, c'est aussi ce qui est
sacré.
Et ce rapport au monde, c'est première
définition de la spiritualité et le
deuxième c'est l'horizon
d'accomplissement de soi. Qui on veut
être ? Qui tu veux être ? Quel est ton
horizon ? Quel quelle est ta mission de
vie ? Je sais pas. d'une façon plus
pragmatique.
Attends, non mais là on n'est pas dans
le pragmatique, je te dis. C'est un
philosophe et moi on parle de
philosophie mais moi j'aime bien ce
rapport au monde et pour moi
euh la modernité on peut enfin on peut
trouver plein de mots mais il y a il y a
trois siècles à la Renaissance en fait
après le Moyen-Âge on est parti dans une
ultra rationalité froide scientist
sèche qui a vidé tout de le sens et le
les liens qu'il y avait. On a asséché
tout ça et maintenant on est en quête de
de sens. Vraiment notre époque, les
jeunes générations é en quête de sens et
de lien et en fait de spiritualité.
Enfin voilà. Après il y a des écueils
évidemment. On peut aller dans le
religieux, retomber dans les structures
de pouvoir, on peut aller dans le new
edge et retomber dans une sorte de truc
un peu bisounours ou je sais pas. Il y a
il y a plein d'écueil, mais je pense que
c'est une voix à creuser, c'est-à-dire
revoir notre rapport au monde qui
comment on considère les animaux, les
plantes, l'univers, nous les humains.
Autrement et je pense que tout tout
notre manière d'être au monde depuis 3
siècles nous a foutu dans la merde. Donc
c'est une des pistes, voilà, encore un
des leviers d'aller requestionner ça et
de remettre en cause ça. Et
moi je trouve que là votre discours est
très irénique. C'est-à-dire que vous
souvent mais
et oui, vous dites il faut il faudrait
que les gens se change leur vue de leur
rapport au monde. Mais moi ce que je
crois et c'est peut-être également
idéaliste, c'est que il faut retourner
aussi vers le rapport de force.
C'est-à-dire que ce changement vers le
spirituel, à mon avis ne peut être
orchestré que par des structures de
pouvoir euh parce que sans ça, on est
dans l'anarchie et disons euh
l'impuissance. Et c'est pour ça que bien
que à thé, je pense que les églises
doivent jouer un rôle majeur et de
saisir du problème du changement de
paradigme. Et ça euh c'est-à-dire les
églises, celles qui sont constituées. On
me dit que il y a une très grande force
des bouddhistes dans toute l'Asie du
Sud-Est avec une imprégnation
considérable à population. Et puis nous
nous connaissons l'Église catholique qui
est une structure de pouvoir, c'est
véritablement exemplaire euh quand je
dis exemplaire comme un exemple euh et
qui devrait devrait se mobiliser. Alors,
il y a il y a un certain nombre de
mouvements à l'intérieur de l'Église
catholique et il me semble que le public
devrait essayer de disons de mobiliser
ses forces.
Mais je suis d'ailleurs très sceptique
puisque comme je pense que c'est la
seule solution et que cette solution me
paraît difficile et peut-être
impossible,
je suis donc inquiet.
Palot
inquiet aussi.
Ouais. Ben moi je connais pas trop
toutes les religions, les structures de
pouvoir dans le monde entier. Enfin,
ici, je vois qu'il y a clairement une
perte de confiance de beaucoup une
partie de la population, une grande
partie de la population envers les
structures religieuses de pouvoir et les
structures
aussi politiques du pouvoir. Euh et du
coup, il y a il y a on a des outils qui
viennent du passé euh mode hiérarchique
pyramidal.
On a un peu peur de ça. Les jeunes
générations sont se méfient. Ils veulent
alors que ce soit la voix extérieure ou
intérieure, la voix politique ou la voix
spirituelle, on va dire, on se méfie des
des des gouvernements classiques de la
de la comment dire changer le monde par
les gouvernements. Voilà, on voit
l'exemple de Nicolas Hul, du ministre
qui peut rien faire. Bah, on se dit
est-ce que c'est encore possible ? et
changer le monde par si on veut prendre
la voie intérieure et spirituelle par
les religions classiques et tout le
catholicisme on se dit c'est pas
vraiment super attirant encore que
l'udat aussi l'encyclique du pape elle
est plutôt stimulante il parle
d'effondrement donc c'est plutôt cool.
Voilà bon ça motive pas tout le monde.
Donc est-ce qu'on peut retrouver
réinventer des structures politiques
moins hiérarchiqu pyramidales moins de
pouvoir ou des structures spirituelles
plus décentralisées ? Ça serait plutôt
sympa. Est-ce qu'on aura le temps de le
faire ? Est-ce qu'on a l'enthousiasme ?
Je sais pas.
Est-ce qu'une bonne dictature verte à
l'ancienne bien ferme, bien
une bonne dictature verte ? Euh euh il y
a Aurélien Barreau qui nous a parlé qui
demande un pouvoir beaucoup plus dur et
beaucoup plus ferme sur les questions
environnementales.
Euh je vais vous poser, on va on va
revenir sur ce sujet après. Je vais vous
poser une question sur le rôle des
médias.
Jacques, comment vous qualifériez-vous
les médias du moment ? Ils sont
effectifs pour informer la population,
il joue leur rôle ? Ça dépend, il y a il
y a effectivement un rôle joué par les
médias, mais il est assez assez nocif et
discutable parce que il y a toujours un
côté euh disons immédiat. Euh ce qui
intéresse les médias, c'est ce qui a
c'est ce qui arrive aujourd'hui.
C'est un monsieur qui a troussidé une
bonne femme. Alors là, ça c'est très
important. Et quand vous regardez la
télévision, ce qui a été malheureusement
mon cas parce que j'ai passé un peu de
temps à l'hôpital cette année, vous êtes
faré par le choix euh des sujets qui
sont qui sont traités. par exemple
saturation complète pendant des semaines
par monsieur Olidet.
Alidé ?
Oui. Alidé. Tout le monde s'en fiche
mais ça n'empêche qu'on ne parlait que
de ça. Et d'ailleurs ces jours-ci
aujourd'hui même chose les la télévision
est entièrement saturée par les colères
de monsieur Mélenchon qui sont un non
événement une affaire sans importance
aucune. Et donc il y a ce côté d'intérêt
pour l'infement immédiat chez ou
spectaculaire qui revient au même chez
les médias qui à mon avis les les
disqualifient.
Ils sont à bon sens
assez néfastte. Mais je voudrais revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit.
Vous avez parlé des jeunes et ça c'est
un point très intéressant et c'est
d'ailleurs
un peu le le livre que je publie
qui s'appelle
réseau
et qui est édité
chez CNRS édition.
Euh là l'idée est la suivante. Vous avez
des jeunes, des quantités de gens euh
qui ne savent pas quoi faire, euh qui
voudrai faire euh joujou, qui voudraient
faire des euh fabriquer des objets quels
qu'ils soient des drones, des satellites
et ceci euh constitue
un milieu énorme. Il y a des centaines
d'organisations de ce genre en France et
des dizaines de milliers dans le monde.
Et ces gens-là, on pourrait les
mobiliser.
Donc ça veut dire les gens qui sont dans
les fablables, dans chez les hackurs.
Euh j'ai été très impressionné
par un monsieur qui est un dominicain
qui a organisé au mois de mai dernier un
accaton au Vatican.
Et ça pour moi c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait spectaculaire parce que les
leaton c'était des jeunes gens qui
venait pour discuter des problèmes qui
nous ont agité aujourd'hui et qui étaiit
qui étaient capable de se mobiliser pour
adire quelque chose au pape. Et ça je
pense que c'est dans cette direction là
que l'on devrait agir. Et c'est pour ça
que j'ai convaincu le Knest de ce que
nous appelons de créer ce que nous
appelons une fédération et que je vous
ai je vais vous expliquer très
brièvement.
Il y a des structures de pouvoir qui
pourraient être mobilisées car ces
structures de pouvoir pensent comme
nous. Ce sont les les disons les
institutions scientifiques par exemple,
non seulement les académies mais les
organismes de recherche
qui eux sont parfaitement au courant,
sont inquiets et disons publi
constamment des cris d'alerte. C'est euh
la le le mouvement, appelons-le,
écologiste, euh en cours, qui commençait
vraiment à avoir un petit peu d'écho
avec la conférence de Rio en 1892. 1992
19,
excusez-moi 1992,
la conférence a été euh disons engendré
par le rapport de 57 Académies des
Sciences qui est qui a été publié un peu
avant et qui indique que en toute
lettre, et ceci est pas d'aujourd'hui,
c'est pas d'hier, c'est d'avant-hier,
et euh le le l'humanité disent-il,
s'achemine vers une crise majeure.
euh qui est dû euh à aux évolutions euh
de disons euh technologique et
sociologique.
Donc on peut imaginer que toutes ces
structures euh scientifiques, techniqu
pourrait disons jouer un rôle. Et alors
comment comment y arriver ?
Ce que je pense c'est que elles doivent
ces structures doivent s'allier avec la
jeunesse.
Donc vous avez d'un côté pour moi euh
les scientifiques,
le les académies, ce que j'appellerai
des structures verticales et puis
d'autre part ce magma de jeunes qui fait
qui constitue toute la faune des des
fablables et d'autres structures
du même genre inorganisé, y compris
d'ailleurs des gens qui ne sont pas
organisés. mais qui souhaiteraient faire
quelque chose et qui passent leur vie un
peu à pianoter sur l'ordinateur et qui
pourra être modé aussi. Et donc l'idée
c'est de mettre ensemble ces deux
structures l'une l'une structure
verticale et l'autre structure
horizontale pour essayer de disposer
d'une part des connaissances du vertical
et de l'enthousiasme et de la jeunesse
de l'horizontal. Alors nous, le KNÈ, le
centre nationalité spatiale où je
travaille depuis 50 ans, a accepté cette
idée, mais nous voulons simplement euh
disons créer euh une structure de ce
genre dans notre domaine qui est
l'espace. Et donc nous l'avons appelé
fédération et il y a maintenant un an,
le KNES a créé cette fédération entre
d'un côté toute une série de groupements
que nous avons disons fait travailler
ensemble dans ce l'association entre
l'association et le KNES. Alors donc
c'est ça c'est ça le sujet du livre que
j'ai publié. Mais alors cette idée cette
idée de de d'alliance entre la jeunesse
chaotique inorganisé mais enthousiaste
et des structures verticales, elle peut
être
appliquée à beaucoup d'autres domaines
que l'espace. Et par exemple, je j'ai
été voir les gens des océanographes pour
leur proposer
qu'il fabrique une fédération
scénographique. Mais il y a bien
d'autres domaines qui sont des domaines
sociologiques et en particulier celui
dont on parle qui pourrait faire l'objet
de création semblable. Je vais Pablo.
Ouais, je je j'étais pas au courant du
livre et je trouve c'est une bonne idée.
Peut-être qu'il y a aussi un peu
d'irénisme, mais en tout cas c'est
vraiment euh c'est vraiment une bonne
manière de voir les choses. Après, euh
j'hésiterais à dire que les jeunes sont
inorganisés. Je pense qu'il y a des il y
a une émergence d'organisation peut-être
plus réticulaire, isomatique,
décentralisée, organique
dans les milieux informatiques, dans les
milieux
activistes,
même dans les ades et cetera, il y a
quelque chose de plus organique et de
plus décentralisé
euh de anarchique pas dans le sens
chaotique, mais anarchique dans le sens
où on réduit les le pouvoir, les
dominations, la hiérarchie pyramidale,
j'ai l'impression J'ai l'intuition qu'on
a basculé vers une sorte d'époque où le
hiérarchique pyramidal s'effondre et où
les structures qui émergent, c'est
structures plus en en réseau, ça c'est
évident, mais décentralisé, disons
coopérative. Pourquoi ? Parce que le
hiérarchique pyramidal en fait ça
n'existe pas dans la nature. C'est
quelque chose qui est efficace à un
moment donné sur dans un environnement
stable comme le pouvoir militaire. Mais
en fait, quand l'environnement change et
là il change massivement, mais vraiment
il change, c'est c'est démesuré, ces
structures s'effondrent en fait et sont
pas sélectionnées par l'évolution. Dans
la vie, il y a 3,8 milliards d'années
d'évolution de la vie, elle n'a pas
sélectionné les structures hiérarchiques
pyramidales. Dans la forêt, il y a pas
un arbre qui dit "Toi, tu pousses, toi
tu pousses pas." ça passe ça se passe
pas comme ça. Et du coup, les les
organisations
qu'on peut voir chaotique, mais je pense
qu' ont une organisation plus
décentralisé sont vachement plus
résilientes, peut-être moins efficaces
sur certains points mais ell elles
dureront plus. Et il y a un côté
basculement,
c'est intéressant à notre époque là de
de peut-être de voir ce chaos et du coup
cet effondrement comme une possible un
possible terro de renaissance de on sait
pas quoi. Il y a quelque chose, on est
dans le brouillard là, il y a des jeunes
poussent, ça part dans tous les sens
mais c'est plutôt ça qui est stimulant.
Moi, je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
vous parce que sur la disons le côté
éphémère des structure verticale, j'ai
écrit un livre un gros livre le chiff
songe pour expliquer que toutes les
grandes per scientifiques ont été d à
des institutions verticales qui ont été
créées par ce que j'appelais le prince.
Alors là, je vous donnerai un simple
exemple très célèbre, c'est la
Alexandrie. Alexandrie
a été
euh euh la capitale euh du d'un des
généraux les plus influents d'Alexandre,
Ptolémé. Ptolemé a voulu faire de
l'Égypte qui était très riche mais un
pays un pays terrain terrestre une
grande puissance navale et pour disons
soutenir son impérialisme naval il a
créé des institutions verticales
scientifiques qui sont très célèbres la
plus important c'était le musée qui
regroupait une cinquantaine de de de
savons pour pour faire avancer la
science qui intéressait la technologie
navale et c'est il y a je ne vais pas
vous donner la liste extrêmement célèbre
des membres du musée enfin je peux vous
indiquer qu'il y a eu clé des archimèes
enfin et cetera et l'autre l'autre
institution de Ptolemé c'était la
bibliothèque qui était liée tout à fait
naturellement au musée et donc et ça ça
a été ça a été éphémère ça a duré 150
ans Mais pendant ces 150 ans, il y a eu
un disons une révolution complète qui
s'est établie
dans l'esprit humain avec ce que
j'appelle la création de la science.
J'ai trouvé en regardant euh dans le
courant d'histoire, j'ai trouvé que ceci
s'est reproduit à 6 ou 7 six ou sep fois
avec des grandes ou des petites tailles
et mais que chaque fois qu'il y a eu
véritablement une percée, elle était à à
une institution. Je donnerai un autre
exemple qui est admirable, c'est la
petite institution créée par le roi
Danemark
au 16e siècle qui est c'est
l'observatoire de Tico Braée qui a créé
la révolution de l'astronomie qui était
indispensable à la révolution de toutes
les autres sciences. Alors je m'arrête
là-dessus sur les sur les exemples, mais
je crois que contrairement à ce que vous
pensez les structures verticales ne sont
pas éphémères. Elles sont elles jouent
un rôle et puis après ça elles vont
disparaître mais elles ont eu le temps
et qui peut être 10 150 200 ans pour de
disons de
de marquer les évolutions. Et donc ce
que je pense à l'heure actuelle c'est
que il faut utiliser les deux. Vous avez
le disons le magma horizontal dont il
faut véritablement
utiliser les forces mais en même temps
si nous les marions avec la force,
l'intelligence, l'organisation
des puissances verticales, alors à ce
moment-là, ce mariage étant ce que
j'appelle une fédération, alors à ce
moment-là, vous pouvez penser que vous
allez avoir une forte influence
Pablo,
ouais, là je suis assez d'accord. Bon,
après,
c'est 150 ans pour moi, c'est court et
c'est éphémère parce que j'étais dans le
temps long de l'évolution. Euh les
pyramides, c'est un exemple aussi de
pouvoir hiérarchique pyramidal. Après,
quelques milliers d'années après, on
sait même plus où elles sont. Elles sont
ensouveles sous le sable. Elles ont fait
des réalisations. Les Égyptiens, c'était
des réalisations immenses. Maintenant,
c'est un peu comme le déchet nucléaire,
non ? Ouais, j'espère pas mais ouais,
c'est un peu ça. Et euh alors là, je
trouve intéressant cette euh ce côté euh
vertical, horizontal ensemble parce que
là on est en situation d'urgence et la
puissance du vertical peut nous aider à
aller vite et fort.
Donc une dictature par contre,
ben dictature, n'allons peut-être pas si
loin. Il y a il y a voilà des normes,
des règles, comme dit Aurélien Barreau,
à un moment ça tu as pas le droit, ça tu
as le droit. Voilà. Après dictature,
j'en sais rien parce que là c'est un
pouvoir centralisé. Je sais pas ce qu'on
en fera hein, mais il y a il y a un
moment une force. Il y a des normes
sociales. Tous les groupes humains
fonctionne avec des normes sociales. Ça
tu peux pas faire ça, tu fais voilà le
le bien, le mal, la morale toutes les
forces qui de cohésion d'un groupe, bah
à un moment il y a il y a des normes et
il faut les faire respecter. Voilà. Et
donc ce que je voulais dire c'est que
j'ai perdu le fil. Euh les
donc il faut les faire respecter. Il
faut les faire respecter. On va parler
du capitalisme.
Ah bon ? J'ai perdu.
Et comment comment avoir un cap
écologique avec un modèle capitalistique
qui est profondément agressif et
corrosif sur notre biotope ? Jacques ?
Mais justement le genre de structure que
je propose fédération euh est commence
mement. Elle a pas besoin de pouvoir
politique, elle a pas besoin de durer
très longtemps. Et je vous dirais un
exemple qui vous paraîtra peut-être
irritant mais qui pour moi est très fort
et qui a été la raison pour laquelle par
laquelle enfin c'était c'est par quoi a
commencé toute ma réflexion, c'est la
l'invention de l'espace. L'invention de
l'espace, elle elle disons elle est été
crosée par la mise au point de fusée
balistique.
Les gens qui ont créé des fusées
balistiques,
c'est une structure verticale qui était
la direction des
des armements de l'armée allemande en
1930. Ces gens-là se sont mis dans
l'esprit de mettre au point des fusées
balistiques. Ils sont réussi en disant.
Et après ça, le pouvoir politique,
c'est-à-dire Hitler là est venu et les a
poussé. Mais malgré tout, ce sont c'est
cette structure cette structure quelle
que soit l' tout en haut, c'est cette
structure qui a joué un rôle capital
puisque ils ont réussi les fusé
balistiques et en plus ils ont réussi à
tuer des gens avec. Alors ça
quelle performance ! Alors ça ça c'est
ça qui a amené le pouvoir politique
aussi bien en Union soviétique qu'aux
États-Unis ou même qu'en France à
récupérer l'idée et cetera qui était
rangée au magasin des fous et a récupéré
cette idée pour en faire quelque chose
que les scientifiques après ça ont
transformé et ça c'était une grande
structure horizontale la communauté
scientifique en satellite. Et donc là,
on est en présence de une structure
verticale qui qui a duré 10 ans. Elle a
été très courte, mais elle a suffi à
mettre les moyens nécessaires et qui
étaiit pas très sympathique. Mais alors
là, c'est peut-être quelque chose que je
reprocherai aux écologistes, c'est leur
phobie du nucléaire.
On reviendra sur nucléaire après. Euh ma
question concernait le capitalisme et ce
modèle corrosif sur le le biotop. Pablo,
Jacques Pablo, le capitalisme, qu'est-ce
que tu en penses ? Moi euh
on continue à fond.
Alors là, c'est parti pour la gloire.
Non, non, mais ouais, on m'a m'a souvent
proché de pas assez parler du
capitalisme et cetera. Je pense que
ouais le l'accumulation
infinie de profit enfin c'est en train
de de bousiller la planète, nos
relations humaines, tout tout.
Euh la là où ça me gêne un peu, c'est
que faut pas que ça cache enfin c'est un
arbre qui cache la forêt. Je pense qu'il
y a des causes de l'effondrement, moi je
t'en trouve 25. Il y a pas que le cap,
il y avait pas que le capitalisme et du
coup faut pas que ça cache d'autres
causes.
Donc au moins 5 sur les 25.
Non mais tu as il y en a qui vont te
dire ouais mais non c'est l'invention de
l'agriculture, l'invention de la
civilisation, mais non c'est le
patriarcal qui va dire mais non c'est la
modernité, c'est la faute des femmes.
Non c'est la faute des femmes si tu
veux. La faute de la séparation nature
culture. La faute de
voilà. Il y a alors tu vois le le l'URSS
était pas capitaliste, ce que je sache,
et il y avait quand même pas mal de
problèmes.
C'est du capitalisme d'État. Ce qu'on
appelle le communisme, c'est du
capitalisme d'État.
Le socialisme du capitalisme d'État. Là,
c'était clairement planifié, je veux
dire. Et ça pour moi un une des causes
majeures, bah on peut revenir sur le
capitalisme après, mais c'est à Marx,
c'est l'économisme, c'est le fait
d'avoir d'être revenu hors sol. Marx il
dit il y a deux facteurs de production,
c'est le travail et le capital et les
ressources naturelles. Elles sont mon
gars et tu oublies tout le reste du
monde, tu oublies tout. Je veux dire, tu
es tu es hors sol, tu parles que du
travail des humains, du rapport l'argent
et les humains. Mais tout le système
terre, il est où ? Oh ben il est
gratuit, c'est abondant, on le compte
pas dans nos équations. Était fou.
Et alors c'était un produit de son
époque, c'était voilà, on peut
historiquement ça se comprend mais là il
y a eu une bifurcation qui a fait qu'on
est parti complètement hors sol et et ça
le le communisme et le capitalisme son
pris les pieds dedans quoi. Je veux dire
alors oui dans le capitalisme il y a un
côté individuel je veux tout égoïste
rationnel homoéconomicus qui est hyper
toxique qui détruit les liens sociaux
qui est vraiment abominable. Donc il y a
les une lutte, je veux dire les luttes
anticapitalistes euh sont toujours les
bienvenus euh dans pour pour euh voilà
pour faire avancer le schemic, mais il
faut pas oublier oublier d'autres causes
et surtout l'interaction entre toutes
ces causes. Moi, je pense que euh le
capitalisme n'a n'a rien à voir avec le
problème et que parce que comme vous
l'avez dit, nous avons vu des régimes et
nous voyons des régimes qui ne sont pas
capitalistes comme le régime chinois.
Euh puis et ah ben non, vous pouvez pas
dire que c'est un régime capitaliste. Le
régime soviétique n'était pas c'était
quelque chose d'autre. Et donc ce n'est
pas du tout le cadre politique qui joue
un rôle. ce qui ce qui joue un rôle euh
c'est le consumérisme de chacun et ceci
n'a rien à voir avec le système
politique. Et donc euh accuser le
capitalisme ou ou d'autres régimes euh
ne rentre absolument pas du tout dans le
problème. Le problème est un problème et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je parle de
solution spirituelle parce que elle est
en dehors de toute considération
politique.
Ça c'est à mon sens d'abord je ne suis
pas forcément d'accord avec votre
critique du capitalisme. Je ne suis pas
pour ou contre, mais je considère que je
suis pas d'accord avec votre votre
affirmation que le capitalisme a
engendré toute cette toute cette horreur
euh de disons moral
un peu quand même non ? Mais a il a
aussi engendré beaucoup d'autres choses
comme euh le niveau de vie, euh le la
l'assurance euh de donné à une grande
partie de la population mondiale euh de
la santé et de la nourriture. Alors
c'est pour ça que c'est une fausse
piste. C'est une fausse piste. Ce n'est
pas là qu'il faut chercher des
solutions.
Je peux répondre ?
Non. Non. Bien sûr. Vas-y.
Mais moi, je trouve que le capitalisme
c'est plus qu'un problème économique. Le
capitalisme, ça donne un horizon, un
avenir. Et en ça c'est c'est un peu une
question anthropologique voire
spirituelle. Le capitalisme est
anthropologique. Ça donne un horizon
d'avenir. Si vous dites à des gens
"L'horizon c'est le bonheur, c'est la
consommation, la consommation et
gavez-vous d'objets et on s'en fout des
autres et chacun pour soi." C'est
Dieu pour tous.
C'est un horizon d'accomplissement de
soi et c'est un rapport au monde qu'on
qu'on vous donne. Donc pour moi, il y a
il y a c'est ça qui est toxique.
Après bon après il y a eu effectivement
des avancées techniques, le bien-être et
cetera. d'une partie de la population
euh je veux dire les les ultra riches
ont bénéficié euh de beaucoup de choses
et il y a des classes qui ont qui ont
été laissé sur le carreau.
Je veux dire bon, on va pas faire ici la
critique du capitalisme mais c'est une
des causes euh une des causes
Non, moi je pense que vous que vous euh
vous avez tort et là il y a il y a eu
c'est c'est ce que vous votre discours
est très vieux. Il est très vieux parce
que il correspond à ce que
au à ce que disait les gens depuis 50
ans qu'il faut le faire la des gens de
extrême gauche qu'il faut faire la
révolution. Et c'est ça que vous dites
en réalité, c'est que il faut ce qui se
passe de mal, c'est que le système
économique euh perverter l'âme humaine.
C'est ça que vous dites. Moi, je pense
que c'est l'âme humaine qui pervertit
euh le système. C'est tout à fait
différent. Et c'est pour ça que c'est
l'âme humaine qu'il faut attaquer et non
pas et non pas les systèmes politiques
euh et comme l'ont fait beaucoup de
générations qu'ils ont précédé euh sans
sans aucun succès.
Mais c'est les deux hein l'âme et le
système se bon
se la balle. Alors moi moi j'aimerais
bien parce que dans tes questions, il y
a un petit peu la
je dézoome un peu, tu parlais de
dictature verte et à un moment
capitalisme et on connaît bien le
capitalisme vert, le green washing et
c'est parti pour la gloire. Et là, il y
a on voit en fait les deux mains du
libéralisme
philosophique. J'entends la main gauche
et la main droite. La main droite, elle
donne des prix aux choses à tout et
elleutise le marché pour réguler. Mais
ça marche pas le marché tout seul. Il
faut la main il faut l'autre main, la
main gauche qui donne un droit à tout et
qui avec un état peut garantir une
stabilité du marché et en fait des
sociétés. C'est ça le libéralisme, main
gauche, main droite, droit, marché,
état, marché.
On peut et le problème de nos sociétés
c'est que si on pousse ces logiques à
fond, tu as le capitalisme vert d'un
côté, c'est abominable et le enf d'un
point de vue écologique en tout cas et
la dictature verte si on pousse la
logique. Donc pour moi le problème il
est plus en amont, c'est la taille des
systèmes, c'est la démesure et l'échelle
et des systèmes. Et on a dépassé des
seuils euh de taille de système qui qui
sont devenus euh euh au-delà du seuil de
convivialité en fait.
Au début, tu as des petits systèmes
techniques qui nous libèrent et au-delà
d'un seuil de conviviualité, ça a été
théorisé par Ivanilic dans les années
70, le système technique devient trop
grand et alienne son créateur. Par
exemple, la voiture, ça te libère parce
que au début, tu peux aller plus vite.
Sauf que un moment, tu as tellement de
voitures que tu passes plus de temps
dans les embouteillages, ça t'alienne.
L'école, ça libère, ça apprend à lire et
à écrire. Sauf qu'à un moment, il y a
trop d'écoles, ça norme, ça fait que des
moutons, ça t'alienne et cetera.
L'hôpital, c'est pareil et tout. Et là,
le système global, économique, politique
sont c'est des macrosystèmes qui sont
devenus trop complexes, trop chers en
énergie pour maintenir trop trop et
cetera. Jacques en parle bien dans ses
bouquins et c'est devenu aliénant et on
est verrouillé dans ces macrosystèmes et
on on risque vraiment le les menaces,
c'est ça, c'est aller vers trop de euh
de capitalisme, de démesure en fait dans
tous les sens du terme parce qu'on a des
trop gros systèmes. Qu'est-ce que c'est
réduire la taille du système ?
simplifier un système, c'est ce que
l'archéologue Joseph Tinter appelle un
effondrement, une simplification des
macrosystèmes. C'est un effondrement.
Voilà. Alors, ça peut être choisi,
dirigé, je sais pas, j'en doute. Subi,
en tout cas, effondrement, renaissance,
ça fait partie des des dynamiques. Et la
possibilité aussi, il faut vivre avec la
possibilité que ça ne renaisse pas non
plus. Ça ne puisse ne pas renaître.
Jacques, la thermodynamique
d'une fusée qui s'emballe, qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Elle explose.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
va exploser ?
Oui. Oui, bien sûr. Je je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que la le système n'est
pas n'était pas soutenable, que les
ressources naturelles ne nous permettent
pas au niveau la consommation actuelle
de rester dans une un état quasi avant
la fin du siècle,
un état convivial.
convivial pas pour tout pas pour tout le
monde. Je peux rêve de dire stable,
quasi stable. Et donc euh il est tout à
fait évident pour moi euh que il y aura
un problème que nous ne comprenons pas à
l'heure actuelle. Nous savons pas ce que
ça sera. On peut imaginer par exemple
qu'il y a des des rigolos euh qui
développent le virus de la variole par
exemple. ce qui pourrait euh créer une
épidémie inarrêtable.
Euh nous pouvons aussi avoir une un
changement d'état dont vous parlez tout
à l'heure euh comme par exemple euh
le détournement du Golfstream ou la ou
la fonte de l'Antarctique qui
véritablement crée le chaos. Donc il va
y avoir toute une série d'événements
très sérieux qui
impliqueront des populations nombreuses
et donc on peut pas on peut pas arrêter
les conflits. Je donne tout le monde
sait aujourd'hui et la presse le dit que
aujourd'hui il y a un milliard de
d'Africains. En 2000 ils feront 4
milliards.
On est en 2019 là bientôt.
En 2050 ils seront combien ? 4
milliards.
Euh au niveau des chiffres, on est quoi
là ?
Faut fa checker. Je sais
faut fa checker là. Les les africains,
ils sont combien en ce moment ?
De l'ordre d'un milliard, de 2 milliards
en 2050 et 4 en en 2100.
Voilà.
Voilà. L'ordre de grandeur. Euh vous
avez revenons par exemple à l'Égypte.
L'Égypte a 90 millions d'habitants. En
2050, ils seront 150. Et à ce moment-là,
alors ils seront en état de stress
hydrique total.
Alors ça veut dire que des millions
d'Égyptiens voudront traverser à Métare.
Ça sera pas 100000 ou 200000 migrants
que vous allez voir, mais des millions
de gens. Ça donc ce genre de choses dont
nous savons qu'elles vont arriver et
bien c'est ça qui va amener, je veux pas
du tout utiliser le mot catastrophe que
je déteste mais qui vont amener des
changements.
La chiant. La chian. Non, ça vous va
pas. Non, des changements. On n pas, moi
je n'appelais pas le mot de
réchauffement climatique, mais de
changement climatique. Et là, c'est
pareil, il y aura des changements, des
changements dans les les rapports
internationaux, des changements dans les
habitudes. Et je pense que en même temps
que cette évolution générale, il va y
avoir une évolution technique.
Je suis très frappé par l'évolution de
l'électronique qui pour moi depuis 1960
que ressort de l'histoire avec des
impacts énormes que nous ne
mesurons absolument pas
dans les relations humaines. Et donc
nous avons toute une série de courbes
d'évolution croissante vers le non
supportable. Donc effectivement je crois
que il se passera des choses et ces
choses seront mauvaises parce que quand
vous avez une épidémie de varié
de l'humanité qui disparaît en 3 mois,
ça ça s'appelle un changement.
Un changement. Et euh ça va arriver.
Donc une profession qui va fortement
augmenter, c'est croquement mort. C'est
ça. Donc cro
pas sûr parce qu'il y aura plus de
crement.
Oui.
C'était ce qui est arrivé quand on avait
des épidémies de peste. Les gens qui
ramassaient les cadavres mouraient avant
avant les autres et donc le croque mort
n'est pas éternel. Oui. Pablo, est-ce
que avec ce constat un petit peu
anxiogène,
toi qui a des enfants, qui a décidé de
te mettre un peu au vert, est-ce que
comment tu fais pour élever tes enfants
en connaissance de cause ?
Pour l'instant, je en parle pas parce
qu'ils sont petits, ils ont 4 et 6 ans.
Euh,
quel âge tu as ?
Moi, j'ai 40 ans. Euh,
en fait, je suis assez d'accord avec le
constat. euh que que tu fais Jacques et
j'ai remarqué que dire les choses comme
ça euh
de manière si abrupte
à des générations qui ont des jeunes
enfants ou des femmes enceintes et
cetera, ça passe pas du tout le message,
ils sont génér
et je pense qu'il faut être
scientifique, faut être là depuis
longtemps dans les chiffres, faut être
faut je sais pas, il y a un truc pour
pour être OK avec avec avec tout ça
facilement. Il y a je sais pas en fait
mais
la froideur de la donnée,
il y a il y a un peu de ça mais je pense
que on peut pas on peut pas se contenter
que de la froideur des chiffres. Et du
coup moi je j'essaie de travailler des
postures de voir comment ces chiffres
peuvent être compris, crus, enfin je
veux dire digérés par une diversité de
gens et les femmes enceintes, les les
jeunes couples qui ont des des enfants
et cetera.
Je pense que le
tous ces chiffres ne doit doivent être
mis dans un récit. Finalement, quand on
parle d'effondrement, c'est un c'est une
mise en récit des chiffres abominables,
quoi. Tu vois, tu as des chiffres sur
l'eau, le pétrole, le climat, c'est
horrible. Tu prends ces chiffres et je
vous je vous dis, c'est un effondrement
qui est en train d'arriver.
L'effondrement, c'est un récit. C'est
une mise en histoire. Et le la clé c'est
que ces récits qu'on se raconte
n'écrasent pas l'avenir, n'applattissent
pas notre avenir. Pourquoi ? Parce que
l'annonce des catastrophes
est toxique en elle-même. Quand on vous
dit vous avez une maladie incurable, par
exemple, on te fait un test génétique et
les scientifiques, les médecins te
disent "Bon euh là tu as je sais pas tu
as quel âge ? 40 ans euh
beaucoup moins
beaucoup beaucoup moins euh
et ben à 60 ans
tu vas euh ton corps va se déformer, tu
vas avir mourir rapidement ou je sais
pas 50 ans d'atroce souffrance. Ce soir,
c'est fiesta Tinder.
Pour l'instant, tu as rien mais il y a
un test scientifique génétique qui te
dit en fait tu as une maladie génétique
incurable et tu vas mourir dans atroce
souffrance. Ne pense même pas que tuas
enfin voilà, tu en as pour quelques
années à vivre. ces n ces annonces
scientifiques, carrées, tout ce que tu
veux sont toxiques parce qu'elles te
changent ta vie au moment présent, elle
te pourrissent la vie et en fait tu peux
vivre encore quelques années, tu peux
essayer de les vivre bien, tu vois. Et
c'est ça la différence, c'est que de pas
rendre les annonces toxiques au point de
pourrir la vie la vie des gens, ça c'est
vraiment délicat et je pense que les
scientifiques, alors les médecins, ils
travaillent depuis des années, comment
annoncer à quelqu'un un cancer et
cetera. Donc il y a toute une science
qu'on décrit dans notre nouveau bouquin
euh d'ailleurs qui sort aujourd'hui. Une
autre une autre fin du monde est
possible
au seuil. Alors on développe tous ces ce
côté psychologique, éthique artique.
Est-ce que ça ressemble à des soins
paillatifs appliqués à quelqu'un qui a
85 de cuit ?
Ça peut
mais ça peut s'appliquer à celui qui a
185 de cuit aussi.
Je veux dire, on est en on pourrait dire
que toute l'humanité entre dans une
phase de soin palliatif. On pourrait le
dire. Je veux dire, c'est c'est ça pour
en fait c'est ce qu'on est en train de
dire ce soir. Soin palliatif, on prend
soin du patient. On lui fait passer les
phases du deuil, colère, tristesse, on
accueille pour qu'il soit dans
l'acceptation de la mort. Accepter la
mort, c'est simplement être adulte. Tu
passes de l'adolescence à l'adulte. Tu
acceptes la mort et les souffrances.
tu acceptes ta vulnérabilité, tu es
humble. Voilà. Et nous, on est dans une
société adolescente, patoolescente, qui
veut pas voir les limites, qui veut pas
voir les souffrances, qui veut pas voir
la mort, qui veut pas voir la possible
fin. Et ça crée un environnement
toxique. On est toxique, socialement
toxique. Pour moi, c'est mon c'est notre
analyse. Et donc passer à l'âge adulte,
c'est reconnaître la mort possible dans
quelques années, mais il y a quelques
années encore, on peut bien vivre avec
l'idée de la mort. C'est ça la
l'histoire de la philosophie, c'est
comment bien vivre avec l'idée de la
mort. Et là, on parle d'un effondrement
de la société, c'est-à-dire la mort de
notre société, de la biosphère, de notre
espèce. Tout est possible encore. Je
veux dire, ça dépend de des boucles de
rétroaction et tout ça. Donc là, on
parle de la mort en général. Alors,
accepter ça, ça veut pas dire ne rien
faire, ça veut dire commencer à être
dans une posture où on va pouvoir
bah enfin voilà, se mettre en en marche,
faire quelque chose, essayer de bien
vivre avec et on sait même pas si ça va
réussir ou pas mais on va essayer de
bien vivre ces années-là, ces années de
tempête.
Si on parlait de la mort,
si vous voulez,
je vois pas très bien qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire de de nouveau, d'intelligent.
J'ai j'ai une phrase j'ai une phrase qui
me trotte dans la tête depuis qu'on se
connaît, c'est "Je sortirai de ce monde
où l'action n'est pas sœur du rêve".
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
C'est un poème de Baudler
qui s'appelle Rédemption,
la renoncement de Saint-Pierre.
Oui, c'est ça. Excusez-moi, je je me
suis trompé comm. Et donc effectivement,
c'est un beau vert et je l'ai utilisé
comme le titre d'un livre. s'appelle
l'action sort du rêve.
Mais je pense que Bler s'est
complètement trompé et justement
justement dans ce monde l'action est la
sœur du rêve. Et d'ailleurs, il me
semble que je ne sais plus quel quel
poète a dit
il y a deux manières de conduire sa vie.
la la faire ou la rêvé. Et moi je pense
qu'il y a une troisème 3è bois,
l'affaire et la rêvée. Et donc je crois
je crois personnellement que le il y a
effectivement deux composantes dans
notre vie, une composante virtuelle, une
composante réelle et que une vie réussie
consiste à disons jouer sur les deux
tableaux.
On parle on parle de d'action, de rêve.
Est-ce que le problème, je vous pose la
question à tous les deux d'ailleurs,
est-ce que est-ce que le problème actuel
c'est que on manque de rêve ? Est-ce que
les rêves qu'on nous propose ou est-ce
que les rêves qu'on est capable de rêver
ne sont pas à la hauteur de l'histoire ?
Euh non, moi je pense pas que on manque
de rêve. Euh je
C'est quoi votre rêve en ce moment ?
Oh ben dites à 92 ans, on n pas de rêve
hein.
Comment ça on a pas de rêve à 92 ans ?
Qu'est-ce que vous faites ce soir ? On
va rêver un peu.
Non mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
On a tout vu. On a tout vu.
On a tout vu.
Ah oui.
Ah ça c'est pas sûr. Attention Jacques,
il faut pas nous lancer des défis.
Quand vous aviez notre âge, c'était quoi
votre rêve ?
Quand j'avais votre âge ?
Oui.
Bon j'étais un grand acteur de l'espace
hein. Alors pour moi le rêve c'était de
donner à l'humanité des nouveaux outils
et à l'humanité entière. C'est-à-dire,
j'ai toujours été j'ai été un de ceux
qui ont créé l'agence spatiale
européenne et j'ai toujours travaillé à
la fois avec les soviétiques et avec les
Américains en pr en pleine guerre froide
euh pour ce que je pensais que et
d'ailleurs ceci est en train de se
produire.
L'administrateur d'An dépit de la
politique de monsieur Trump veut
travailler avec les Chinois. Et donc il
y a dans chez les scientifiques et en
particulier chez les spatiaux chez les
scientifiques beaucoup plus que partout
ailleurs dans la population le désir de
créer une société humaine unique. Et
c'est ça un rêve et c'est pour ça que je
pense que le genre de suggestion que je
fais de fédération multiple parce que y
compris une fédération où le bras
vertical serait l'église catholique
c'est oui c'est pourquoi pas c'est c'est
mon rêve ça mais
je ne pense pas que je le verrai arriver
mais en tout cas il me semble que
Sauver l'humanité, c'est un rêve,
Pablo.
Un rêve, un cap, la jeunesse
pour moi. Moi,
ouais.
Ah
ouais, j'ai enfin j'ai plein de rêves.
Moi je trouve déjà que notre époque
manque de rêve, de capacité,
d'imagination, de déployer des horizons
et cetera. C'est euh
c'est un Ouais, ça s'est un peu asséché.
Euh je pense que enfin je dis souvent
les artistes, les romanciers,
enfin les scénaristes et cetera, ils ont
vraiment beaucoup de boulot à faire pour
déployer des nouveaux horizons. Moi mon
rêve, bon moi je suis irénique hein. Je
suis un peu comme Jacques.
Ça se taille he ça taille.
Mais moi, j'ai rien contre l'irénisme,
je trouve. C'est c'est très sain de
vouloir la paix. Enfin voilà, on a pris
ça comme une C'est péjoratif. Pourquoi
c'est péjoratif de vouloir la paix ? Ça
m'énerve ça. Bref, et du coup
c'est peut-être utopiste.
Et alors c'est bien l'utopie. Enfin, je
veux dire il y a il y a des trucs, c'est
un horizon. Enfin voilà, maintenant on
parle de postopie, des territoires où on
essaye des choses. Voilà. J'aime bien
j'aime bien tout ce qui se crée en ce
moment. Il y a des il y a des failles,
je veux dire, il y a des effondrements
des systèmes de pensée, des des failles
dans je sais pas les systèmes politiques
et cetera. et ça crée des brèches. Et en
fait dans un trottoir quand il y a une
brèche, bah il y a une mauvaise herbe
qui pousse. Et j'aime bien toutes ces
mauvaises herbes. Je pense aux ades et
et par mauvais herbes c'est pas
péjoratif. Je pense mauvais herbes de
brassinces. Et les mauvaises herbes,
c'est les plantes pionnières. C'est
celles qui se qui se mettent là où c'est
difficile, là où c'est austère. C'est
les c'est celles qui qui prépare le
terrain pour que les arbuses puis les
arbres puis la forêt arrivent et se
déploient. Il y a un bouquin qui m'a qui
m'a marqué de Anna Ting, une
anthropologue américaine qui le bouquin
s'appelle le champignon de la fin du
monde. Euh je crois que c'est la
découverte. Et en fait, elle euh elle
étudie un
euh l'économie, l'anthropologie d'un
champignon, le Matsutake, un champignon
japonais qui est très bon
qui pousse, qui est bon, qui est qui
peut être cher aussi, il y a tout un
commerce et cetera, mais qui pousse dans
les milieux dévastés quand on a détruit
la forêt, quand quand le voilà le je
sais pas la silviculture verticale
tac qui a qui a coupé tous les armes,
qui a vendu tout ça et qui a exploité et
il y a il y a juste des débris dans les
ruines du capitalisme de ce que vous
voulez la modernité et là il y a les
champignons qui poussent horizontaux
décentralisés et ça recrée ça ça recrée
de la vie et ça prépare encore la enfin
ce qui peut suivre et j'aime bien j'aime
bien ces petites mauvaises herbes qui
partent dans tous les sensement il y a
beaucoup de choses c'est assez stimulant
mais il y a il y a eu dans l'histoire de
la biosphère cinq grandes extinctions,
c'est-à-dire dire il y a cinq fois et ça
je parle pas de disons de
science-fiction là nous savons que ça
rêvé effectivement où la plupart des
espèces ont disparues. Quand je dis la
plupart ça veut dire 90 à 95 %.
Donc c'est arrivé cinq fois où ça
quelques millions d'années pendant
lesquels
vous avez 95 % des espèces qui ont
disparu. Même la première c'est arrivé
dans la mer et toute la vie était dans
la mer et pourtant 95 % des espèces
maritimes ont disparu en quelques
millions d'années. Et puis alors le
système s'est montré assez résilient et
après 100 millions ou quelque chose
comme ça et bien le
il y a une nouvelle
nouvel ensemble de végétaux d'animaux
qui constituent une nouvelle biosphère.
Et donc je vois pas beaucoup dans je ne
vois pas avec d' angoisse euh notre
évolution. Euh à l'heure actuelle, nous
avons une une espèce euh qui est
dominante et qui est ce que j'appelle
méchante. Euh chaque espèce a subi une
évolution où un de ses caractères
devenait dominant et finissait par par
le faire disparaître. Je prends un
exemple, les éléphants et cetera ont
donné des mammouths qui avaient des
teles des telles défenses que ils
pouvaient plus porter. Ils ont fini par
tomber par terre et mourir. Je pense que
la l'espèce humaine,
son caractère principal, c'est la
méchanceté. Et cette méchanceté,
connerie, hein,
et et la et la méchanceté finira par
tuer l'humanité comme les comme le poids
des défenses a tué les les mammouth. Et
donc, ben l'humanité, roi était une
espèce qui a subi une évolution. avec
une un maximum une culmination qui est
sans doute dans notre siècle et puis
après ça il se passera quelque chose
d'autre. Et donc euh moi c'est pour ça
que j'aime pas le mot euh catastrophe
euh parce que il il a il charit une
connotation euh
déplaisante,
angoissante.
Mais ça c'est parce que vous avez 92
ans, parce que vous avez eu le temps de
vivre. Imaginez-vous prendre
connaissance de tous ces faits à nos
âges. Pour nous c'est une catastrophe.
Mais c'est pour ça que je pense que je
pense aux gens qui ont votre âge et qui
veulent réagir. Et c'est pour ça que je
propose des solutions.
Là, on va passer aux questions internet
parce qu'on arrive bientôt à la fin.
Alors, à la volée, je vous pose les
questions. Vous choisissez d'y répondre,
pas d'y répondre et puis ensuite on
arrivera à la fin de notre émission.
Alors, question pour monsieur Blamont.
Est-ce que le rapport Midose a une
quelconque influence sur votre vie dans
les années 70
ces actions ? Le rapport Midose sur le
l'épuisement des ressources, rapport
club d'Europe ?
Oui, le rapport de
club de Rome ?
Non, absolument aucune. À l'époque, on
peut dire que j'étais scientiste. Ce que
je ce que j'ai dit ce que je disais à à
mes amis qu'il y avait deux seules
choses importantes dans la vie.
une façon naturellement euh agressive de
parler, mais ces deux choses c'était la
physique et les Nations Unies. Voilà,
c'est
les femmes quand même un peu non ?
Bon ben ça c'est pas vraiment très
important, c'est la vie quotidienne mais
on va pas se on va pas passer la vie à
se dévouer des femmes. On a autre chose.
C'est très important, ça doit pas être
négligé et cetera. Mais qu'est-ce qu'on
on fait ?
Et donc physique et Nations Unies, ça
veut dire c'était naturellement une
façon très elliptique de m'exprimer. Ça
voulait dire d'une part la science et
d'autre part la paix.
Et donc c'est pour moi c'était les deux,
je veux pas appeler ça des rêves mais
disons c'était les deux grandes causes.
Et donc à ce moment-là la notion disons
de surconsommation
ne m'a pas effleuré mais parce que ça
n'existait pas. La surconsommation est
une affaire du 21e siècle mais
rappelez-vous que il y avait 2 milliards
de gens en 1950 et que maintenant il y
en a 7. Et donc c'est ça la différence.
Naturellement aujourd'hui, on ne peut
pas se trouver dans l'état d'esprit où
on était en 1960 ou quelque chose comme
ça où on ne voyait pas euh l'explosion
de natalité euh qui a suivi.
Donc je pense que notre expérience de
jeune
ne peut pas être transcrite aujourd'hui.
Nous aujourd'hui, nous sommes dans une
situation où finalement les
exponentiels, car il s'agit vraiment
d'exponentiel,
ont finit par créer une situation
qui est incontrôlable. Et d'ailleurs,
quand on a qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
explosion ? C'est une série d'événements
exponentiels qui se su se se se
succèdent
et pour devenir véritablement à une
femme.
Pablo, que pensez-vous des dernières
marches pour le climat qui ont eu lieu ?
Réel début d'une prise de conscience
écologique ou pétard mouillé ?
Ouais, j'espère début d'une prise de
conscience. Après, on n jamais sûr, mais
je pense qu'il y a un nouveau public qui
a été touché là et je pense que avec un
peu de chance, ça peut faire des
exponentiels et boucles de rétroaction.
Euh, on l'a vu aussi il y a un signal
faible, c'était la pétition là, ça peut
paraître anecdotique, mais des
Aurélien Barreau,
non, d'élèves de de grandes écoles, LEN,
Polytechnique et cetera qui qui refusent
de participer au
qui se font embarquer dans les
multinationales et qui refusent de
participer en fait. Donc, il y a une
sorte de voilà même les élites à un
moment, les fils, les jeunes générations
des élites politiques et économiques qui
refusent maintenant qui volent du sens
en fait. qui veulent plus juste faire du
profit. Voilà, c'est des signaux
faibles. Je pense que depuis cet été, il
y a une réelle il y a un basculement
dans l'imaginaire. Il y a eu l'effet
Nicolas Hullo qui a fait "Bon bah ça
fait tomber les masques, le
gouvernement, on peut plus compter
dessus, on fait les choses nous-mêmes."
Il y a eu la l'étude de la planète
étuve, il y a eu les les canicules, il y
a eu cet été, il y a eu un basculement.
On a parlé pas mal d'effondrements et
cetera dans les médias, dans les grands
médias mainstream, en tout cas en milieu
francophone.
Euh
voilà, je pense que c'est Ouais, ça peut
ça peut être un pétard mouillé et ça
peut ne pas l'être. Voilà.
Question pour Jacques. Jacques, la
conquête spatiale est-elle encore
possible si l'on doit réduire notre
consommation énergétique ? Mais
naturellement
euh euh les l'ensemble des activités
spatiales
et joue un rôle pratiquement nul euh en
en ce qui concerne disons son
financement et cetera dans l'économie
mondiale. Euh je donnerai un exemple
typique. Le budget d'Arian Espace est un
milliard. C'est c'est rien. C'est donc
on peut parfaitement imaginer. C'est
quelque chose qui est très amusant,
c'est que le public est absolument
convaincu que l'espace est horriblement
cher. Et ça et ça ça m'est
ça m'est arrivé lorsque j'étais décoré
par Pompidou, il je
il a fait un discours pour c'était une
décoration qui était s'adressait à
l'étatmajor du KNÈ. Euh le monsieur
Pompidou a dit "Vous êtes bien mais vous
êtes cher."
Alors ça ça m'a par ridicule.
Et d'ailleurs je je lui ai dit, je dis
"Je comprends pas ce que vous voulez
dire.
Si où si vous voulez faire d'espace et
bien vous le faites mais dire que c'est
cher, ça n'a aucun sens." Et d'ailleurs,
ce qui est amusant, ce qui m'est arrivé
une anecdote amusante, c'était j'étais à
Londres à la Royal Society et je vois
passer euh mon ami John Hutton euh il
était il était déjeuné,
il était en en frac avec un pantalon
rayé. Alors je lui dit "John, vous êtes
drôlement habillé, il y a qu'une seule
solution, c'est que vous sortez du
dekinam Palace."
et m'a dit "Mais c'est vrai, je viens
d'être décoré par le prince de Gal." Et
qu'est-ce qu'il vous a dit ? "Vous êtes
bien mais vous êtes cher." Et donc il y
a une disons, une légende qui indique
que nous coûtons beaucoup d'argent. En
réalité, ce sont des dépenses
extrêmement modestes. Naturellement, ça
se chiffre par milliard. Le budget de la
NASA est de 20 milliards de dollars.
Peut pas dire que quand vous le comparez
au au milliers
milliers de milliards de dollars euh du
ressources américaines, c'est dans le
bruit de fond.
Donc là, on arrive à la à la fin de
notre émission. Euh euh on termine
toujours par laisser un conseils pour
les jeunes générations. On va commencer
par Pablo.
Ah
et ensuite Jack laissera un conseil pour
les jeunes génération. Pablo,
ah j'ai une citation aussi. Attends,
c'est le moment peut-être de la mettre.
C'était en exerg du bouquin.
Alors, je veux bien que tu nous montres
la couverture du bouquin à la caméra.
Tu l'as ? Une autre fin du monde est
possible.
Voilà.
C'est une situation que j'aime beaucoup
de Wilson qui est un de mes héros, un un
un un biologiste spécialiste des
fourmis. C'est lui qui a rendu populaire
le terme biodiversité et il dit là
récemment aujourd'hui l'humanité est
comme un rêveur ambulant pris entre les
fantasmes du sommeil et le chaos du
monde réel. Nous avons créé une
civilisation Star Wars avec des émotions
de l'âge de la pierre, des institutions
médiévales et une technologie déifiée.
Nous sommes affreusement troublés par le
simple fait d'exister et nous
représentons un danger pour nous et pour
le reste du vivant.
Un grand biologiste doit avoir 90 ans
aussi. Et euh moi ça me fait ça me fait
penser pour les jeunes euh pour les
jeunes générations
qu'il faut il faut deux choses. C'est
aussi ce que dit John Messi, une
écopsychologue américaine, dit il faut
de la sagesse et de la compassion. Et
moi ce qui me manque aujourd'hui, c'est
des anciens. Faudrait que c'était
vraiment un plaisir et je suis très
impressionné de vous avoir rencontré
Jacques.
C'est aux jeunes de chercher des anciens
qui vous font grandir, qui vous qui vous
initient à l'âge adulte. Il y en a pas
beaucoup mais il y en a encore et c'est
précieux.
Nous on a eu beaucoup de chance. On a eu
Jacques et on a eu Marc Hulman qui nous
ont initié à être adulte.
Tiens, d'ailleurs Jacques a une une
équation sur les fourmis à nous citer.
Le le c'est c'est Oh, j'arrive jamais à
me rappeler sur les fourmis. Pas
vraiment. J'admire beaucoup les
spécialistes de fourmis, mais j'en sais
pas.
Si les le théor l'équation sur les
fourmis, sur les réseaux en fourmis, je
ça me reviendra.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Jacques ?
être soi-même.
Euh c'est le conseil d'ailleurs de
Socrate. Il y a rien de nouveau
là-dedans. Euh honnête,
savoir euh s'analyser
et euh choisir des buts à ses à sa à son
niveau. Et je pense que je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure avec l'idée de
Fédération, il y a une manière possible
pour la jeunesse de participer à ce que
à notre civilisation et qui est tout à
fait nouvelle parce que aujourd'hui il y
a quelque chose qui appelle l'hô, il y a
le big data, il y a toute une série
d'armes qui sont à la disposition de
tout le monde et donc ces armes, il faut
les saisir et ça veut dire
vraisemblablement
imaginer de nouvelles structures
sociales comme par exemple la
fédération. Et c'est pour ça que moi je
ne suis pas du tout l'idée qui a été
évoqué tout à l'heure. Tout ça c'est la
faute du capitalisme et cetera. Je ne
pense pas que ça soit dans le jeu
politique habituel et dans les idées
politiques habituelles que que la
jeunesse puisse trouver aujourd'hui un
engagement enthousiasm.
On va on va rester sur ces sur ces
mots-là, messieurs. Merci.
Merci.
[Musique]